[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tell the audience do not tell them my
secret do not tell them my secrets
secret hello hello hello and welcome
back to the break room this is our daily
live show that covers all the nerdy news
nerdy news you need to know right from
our very own break group here at new
rockstars headquarters in a secret
location that we will never ever reveal
uh i'm brandon and on the panel with me
today we've got erica woosher
hi hi
hey friends
we also have jessica clemens
who do you call me
the joker the joker we have the joker
look at the joker isn't she beautiful
tommy bechtol
hey baby
oh oh man everyone's looking real nice
today oh my god keep it gucci to moochie
and don't forget to manscape that
that's some some thirsty thursday energy
yeah we we have got a great show for you
today
uh uh we're gonna be talking about the
joker the joker the joker
[ __ ] you better be joking uh also
batgirl has finally spoken out on being
a bad girl
[Laughter]
uh uh michael keaton is being played
like a piano folks someone tell this guy
what's going on
of course of course we're talking about
moon night and the eternal yeah did you
say the second part to the joker part i
did say this yeah i missed it we had a
lot going on we had a lot going on yeah
it's a little uh euphoria reference for
you kids out there hey for every hundred
dollars today we're to have a great
redemption in honor of the joker too
jessica will be applying her talents on
all of us and jokerfying the rest of us
so every hundred dollars in the
redemption will run a poll you pick who
gets jokerfied much like jessica
clements uh and we will have a fun time
to sit in those super chats you guys
love it when i paint faces yeah now i'm
gonna really paint now she's going hard
uh some say i wake up and look like a
clown every day but you know here we are
hey the break room is also on tick tock
follow us at the underscore break room
that's the underscore break real quick
great content tommy's been putting some
great
tax on the dick throwing out some ticks
some talks some bricks and some rocks
baby yeah so check it out and also if
you're still here watching throw a like
on that video huh put a like on the
video just hit the little like button
uh we got a lot to talk about today
throw your questions in the chat send in
your super chats let's get it going with
some headlines
and this fresh headline just came out of
the oven warner brothers ceo david
zazlaff says they are setting up a team
at dc with a 10-year plan with a
significant focus on quality uh he
actually pointed out kevin feige's
marvel studios model as his inspiration
i'm kidding hey he's heard of them he's
heard of it concerning that
a big idea big ideas going on over there
um yeah this is
kevin feige just this year had said like
oh we met we came up with a 10-year plan
and we're going to go so they're going
to try it too uh i wish them the best of
luck uh you know maybe release some of
the stuff you already shot uh next
headline we're on the street joker 2
will take place in arkham asylum yes
according to an insider with knowledge
on the project a lot of the joker sequel
takes place inside arc of asylum and of
course we got that like i can't wait to
be there teaser revealed today jessica
is asking for a partnership
she only dancing she's gonna be dancing
i might get a job at arkham just to see
me cleaning the floors to watch you
dance
me dad watch her dance
the star the star of batgirl actually
put out a statement uh about what
happened with the canceling of the movie
uh she said uh i am proud of the love
hard work and intention all of our
incredible cast and tireless crew put
into this film over seven months in
scotland i feel blessed to have worked
among absolute great and forged
relationships for a lifetime in the
process to every back row fan thank you
for the love and belief allowing me to
take uh take on the cape and become as
bob said best my own damn hero hashtag
batgirl for life that emoji gotta call
out the batman wow
i just want to bring attention to myself
as the joker would and say that i'm
sorry that i accidentally muted myself
don't know how i did it i thought you
were going for the silent clown thing i
was going for the crazy
that's a crazy behavior i'm going to
slowly mute everyone's bike a couple of
a couple of things from that one did not
realize they were filming that in
scotland did not know that was news to
me so i mean this is still ridiculous i
can't believe this movie is not going to
see the light of day yeah i i'm a
conspiracy tommy has his tinfoil hat on
he says watch this movie come out
we're building a grassroots campaign
they're going to figure out a way to
release this movie under some other
imprint like they'll come out they're
getting like we're doing like dc films
or something like that and it's gonna be
like just like all these movies that
that that have gone far enough in and
they can kind of market they're already
getting free marketing right now every
day that this is trending and people are
talking about it is free advertising for
this movie that some people probably
didn't even know existed i didn't know
it was coming out they're telling me
yeah their first
understanding of this movie was the
announcement that was canceled anyway i
really want to see it i really want to
see it i want to see how good it was or
how bad it was or how neutral it was i
just want to see the finished product
because you know like she said a lot of
people worked really hard to make this
back row movie
give it to the people stop playing you
cowards yeah put it out there we all saw
josh strength fantastic four come on you
can put out bad girl you could put out
back girl okay you're much worse than
that
uh next headline new aquaman 2 reports
reveal why ben affleck is replacing
michael keaton according to multiple
sources keaton also filmed a scene for
the upcoming aquaman the test audience
has found confusing i find the whole
news story confusing
apparently michael keaton's batman was
going to show up in everything i just
like also like nuts i like that my
looking saying yes without thinking
about
what are you doing what's going on
we keep joking that like they just throw
them in a different batsuit put them on
a green screen you're like here's your
lines for today mr keep and he's like
where am i what's going on okay i
thought it was the vulture he goes let's
go let's go let's go next week i'm doing
birdman three let's get it let's get it
going
aquaman two lost kingdom previously was
supposed to open before the flash which
will explain keaton's return but last
week aquaman star jason ramone revealed
that ben fleck was filming a scene as
bruce wayne suggesting keaton has been
replaced with affleck's version of the
character which if you could just
replace batman's does that make even
less sense yes like keaton's batman
would have a very specific reason for
being there yeah affleck's batman would
just be like there yeah i don't know but
we it's so confusing none of it makes
any sense yet
yeah yeah also i want to see it i just
really say super kind of all that uh
michael keaton yeah oh yeah i'm watching
that
also what is batman doing at the bottom
of the ocean i don't know guys next
headline
uh supergirl has found her kryptonite
and is unlikely
to move forward at dc uh this was a
supergirl movie which insiders say uh
was in development and is not likely to
move forward if you caught our show
yesterday we we put it in the safe
category yeah hoping it would fly high
but we we've moved it on the board over
to eliminate it so we were we were
posers yeah i mean i honestly was like
ready for a supergirl movie over like
another superman like give me something
else yeah i don't know maybe people have
a change of heart when they have this
10-year plan meeting yeah maybe who
knows who knows a good old decade a good
decade about a decade uh next headline
marvel's iron heart adds drag race
winner shay coulee to the cat yeah
jessica and tommy are stoked about this
name i am that's my mama that's my baby
and i feel like too many people are
getting upset with it online not
recognizing that shay coulee was an
actor before she was even a drag queen
so her first love was on the stage
second love was drag queen uh so
shut your mouth yeah chill out yeah yeah
don't get angry they made harry styles
uh put them in the mcu
think about it harry styles don't get
mad at her don't be mad at anybody just
wait a minute
on thursday that home record i'll be mad
at him when do i get to not be positive
because we have positive wednesday
positive friday is just going to be a
health scare oh no oh no
fridays uh we ran a couple of polls in
the chat do you think having joker two
set in arkham asylum is a good creative
choice 86 saying yes i mean
they've sort of shown arkham asylum here
and there in the films over the years
but we've never had like a long
tail experience inside of our car which
could be a lot of fun yeah we also asked
do you think we will ever see a solo
background movie ever maybe
maybe 76 percent said maybe i believe
there will be very optimistic i think
they should i just think they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna i feel like
they're gonna release it eventually yeah
just hopefully before i'm 90 years old
do you think do you think much like the
north koreans pressured sony into
changing their plans they could pressure
wb into releasing batgirl i think if we
pressured them into doing morbius
please
reach into your computer databases
find the warner brothers
to put on a performance of a funny thing
happened on the way to the forum
i know
i know you love basketball tommy is the
dennis rodman of the break room he is
going to bridge the game my nickname is
the worm
oh my god you guys i just want to remind
everybody that if we do break that
hundred i get to put one of these babies
yeah the clown makeup not my clown
makeup they'll be my goons uh he'll be
the guns
let me say mrs j
pudding
um charlie quinn
[Laughter]
um today what you guys have probably
seen the thumbnail we're talking about
moon night because the moon director and
oscar isaac might have just revealed
season two plans muhammad were on first
name basis even released in a tweet a
tweet of uh tick tock made that slim and
cairo and oscar isaac being like oh
clearly moon knight two which yeah of
course we're ecstatic about especially
me i would love to see where moon knight
goes because the first season was
beautiful to me
but what's the chance of this really
happening you know i don't want to be
the i don't want to be the bearer of bad
news but it is so like at least like
with eternals um pound noswell was
straight like
yeah she's already working on a draft
like chloe's i was already working on it
and this i'm just like all i hear is
what else could it be and it's like you
guys could be doing press could be doing
anything i think that whole moment as i
said yesterday when the news broke felt
very staged to me i believe that this
was a setup
but lame stream media i will lose my
mind if it is an effort to announce this
movie in some sort of organic viral
moment we're all looking for social
media moments these days literally you
can hire people to create social media
moments for you
why not just create one of your own on a
little vacation to egypt season two is
happening guys that was confirmation all
i need to do is look into the eyes of
those two gentlemen i trust him
i trust him as much as i trust our great
leader in north korea kim jong-un who
will be helping us release the
background
they did make a season two which is
something that i would clearly love what
would season two look like now that
arthur harrow is dead right well maybe
dead i don't know
well that is true we don't know
he's been shot he's been shot we see a
pop pop he also has a god inside of him
so who knows who knows what that means i
mean i would like it if you know they
take this opportunity to continue down a
dark path especially if this is leading
to some sort of midnight sun scenario
we're getting blade you know and disney
plus has broken the our seal by putting
r-rated movies on there
could be time if this just keeps getting
a little darker and darker i would like
season two to get real real creepy yeah
they have all those uh who shot these
two right that are that could be uh yeah
a lot of them fell off the wall some new
guys released some people at least at
least the guys
all gods must live
i'm not the first scorer i'm a raj
all right all right how did you feel
about me
i loved movement i loved oscar isaac's
performances both times
and then the third alternative
yeah you mean his brother who played his
double that's pretty cool yeah getting
checks in the family
you gotta keep it in the family
keep the checks in the family yeah my
brother would act out i would absolutely
love season two of moon knight to come
out eventually yeah i i hope it's not a
one and done well the thing the reason
the i i mean i'm
praying for the season two you guys i'm
not saying that it's not gonna happen
i'm praying for it you're playing are
you gonna be boston or a team
he plays tricks and he hates me uh but i
think when they uh because then we see
something in the emmys where they took
out a title so they could be recognized
for something else
do you remember we talked about that
briefly it was uh oh they took out
limited series limited series so there's
a reason it's where you decide if you
put it on limited series or you put it
on like just drama or comedy or whatever
but they took out that limited series so
that means that could be another push to
be like it's happening
um who are we who did we leave off with
season two there's because i think moon
and i did have a lot of unanswered
questions a lot of things that we didn't
go back to so we have like jake who we
barely saw but we know he's in there so
uh this season could explore him
um and then uh uh leila layla is now
and she has uh the avatar of um tower
right
but her name is layla too right yes yeah
but tyler is like her she's the absolute
right
yeah so we have that and i think we need
to also get into the fact that um
he got out he got out of the tower the
the the field of reads which i think is
impossible it should be chrissy is it
impossible to get out of the field of
reads uh call it if you know okay
can you get out is there anything you
guys are looking forward to and season
two that they probably explore more
other than those three um
i mean like i i would like to know about
this irish guy who's an avatar from one
of the egyptian guys i don't know what
that's all about tell me that story uh
but yeah i want to see more of the gods
freed yeah i want to see what if this
was like konju's big problem like what's
his big problem now
they dealt with ahmed that problem's
resolved like what's his big issue now
what's really really really really also
looking healthy yeah yeah he's looking
down looking healthy in that limousine
he's in a nice suit right wasn't he
wearing like a knife
um from there we also have like i said
earlier patton oswalt basically
confirming that chloe's out close closes
out is writing a sequel to eternals too
we are already missing three eternals
right three eternals got zoop zip zapper
three times got sucked up got sucked up
right we have firearms
in space two are dead ajax is dead and
icarus is going to go go mashems oh that
is i don't think icarus is not that good
at all it is not dead he got too hot and
then was like he's also still probably
on his way to the sun i don't know how
long it's taking him to get there don't
they show
well they show like some sun
something no they never really did baby
no one's ever really dead yeah don't
they show them
they don't show them explode they show
it kind of getting hot but what if he
just flies right through the sun and
comes out the other side like a metal
skeleton is like well that didn't work
um now that uh i think eternals will
hopefully answer where is like the body
of the rest of that celestial that's in
god i hope so that's my biggest right
ajax all dead wait
athena's not dead
at the end oh no
she's on space she's in space yeah
boy if you're watching i'm so sorry
uh point to this movie um do you we
gotta do whatever you watch do you think
the second eternals is gonna happen in
phase six or phase seven
or do you think they're just gonna slide
there's no reason five maybe six six
could happen because it has to happen
before our secret do you think it's
gonna impact secret wars
or king dynasty i feel like that's too
many gods right
never enough gods more guys all gods
must live i am rose
well i think there was like kind of a
story that was floating around that
harry styles like assigned to like
more than one more movie yeah i think
like a couple of things that's like kind
of the standard like boilerplate
contract for like people that come into
marvel they're like they're signed for
multiple projects well that that was
it was kind of like that but now they're
that kind of player like project by
probably sure sure because oscar isaacs
was family just yeah famously just
signed up for that one one thing great
point so i think they're like afraid to
like promise people 40 million down the
line yeah uh because they realize that
line does show up eventually and they're
like whoopsie whoopsie poopsie we'd all
like to be scientists
not heaven it's paradise but there is a
path you have to follow to reach your
eternal peace it's why mark arrived in
the field with no houses or structures
thank you christie oh like it wasn't
ready for yeah it wasn't ready we're not
done
wonderful
is that a famous trope in like stuff
when you go to heaven and heaven's like
it's not your time yet and they send you
back that means all the time yeah right
covers me every night
tommy keeps dying every night we gotta
get you a sleep apnea machine
one for the top one for the bottom
circulating
freshly painted house dry being dried
out that's right i have i have beef with
this patent oswald thing you do i do
you're not a lobster
he's on the yeah he's on the today show
but uh al roker
yeah play the clip play this clip
there's uh harry styles and i are in a
little post credit sequence in the
eternals
we play um i play pit patrol he plays
star fox right um thanos's brother they
have announced there's going to be an
eternal sequel chloe zhao is going to
direct it so hopefully there will be
more adventures of uh
star fox and pip
see there's a lot of like they've
announced no one's announced this yeah
but it's that's a little bit at the end
it said the internals will return right
did you say the attorneys were returning
in terms of it it didn't say
yeah
return yeah but it's too that's a little
too concrete to now for kevin feige to
be like he lied i think patton and oscar
got on the phone that day and they're
like we're gonna we're gonna double hit
him yeah we're gonna hang kevin twice he
can only watch one piece of media
he'll never be able to stop it it's also
like such a weird timing for it to come
out with all the dcu stuff being dropped
because it kind of got overlooked but we
didn't the fans of marvel didn't
overlook that we were like oh great good
confirmed uh yeah what also pisses me
off though wasn't in that clip al roker
sets it up by saying oh you're doing a
movie with harry styles or something
like that oh wow i was like it already
came out my guy yeah and then the rest
of the cast has the audacity to say al
roker's the nerd over here yeah like boy
i wrote her
is too yeah going back to his alma mater
suny oswego where all the geniuses go
drinking at the shed getting wings at
the uh at the thirsty raven we're all
hanging out guys 10 cent wing night at
muldoons it's going to be freaking wild
actually i think that's the university
of buffalo
i drink all over that state
painter i agree with you i think oscar
could be joking but pat is telling the
truth but i do
but at the end of the day are we looking
more forward to a season two of moon
night or eternals two and i will i love
the eternals but i want if i had to
choose between the two um please give me
moonlight yeah please
night all day one night i'm i'm real
hyped for new journals too because i
feel like eternals one did a lot of the
hard work of like
explaining things laying stuff out
showing how it's worked over two
thousand years on earth great we've
eaten our vegetables give me my dessert
baby 100 i want to see more just like
robot battle more more celestials i want
to see all that stuff like that that
gets me hyped up my whole thing is like
i just want eternals to
answer all of my my plots like all my
things that were unanswered well if
that's our if that's our standard for
these movies they have to please me
well they don't have to appease me but i
was like there was there's so many it's
not even plumbers i guess it's more so
questions
you guys uh it's a movie that i assumed
you were only gonna have one of and i
was very like
oh you didn't answer this or this or
this or this also
i like the post-credits scene and i want
to see more of where this is going um
but moon night was is a series so it has
more time to explore that world and so
the second season of that is just
exploring more of them maybe even
sending us out for midnight signs that
makes sense ernest esteban standing on
the super chat saying eternals two the
gods must be crazy movie starts with a
celestial dropping a coke bottle from
his face if you know you know i know
i'm an old man somebody's watched comedy
central on a sunday afternoon for five
straight years yes uh and keep sending
in those super chats we're just over
sixty dollars right now and at a hundred
dollars someone will get their face
painted like a clown that's right
all these smooth faces and speaking of
smooth faces and bods
really quick people have been coming in
just now which thank you for showing up
and keep questioning in the chat why is
jessica in this why dressed like this
because we were just talking about the
promos for joker2
with
i have a meeting after this and if you
want to see me go to it in clown makeup
uh we're gonna have to give also quick
reminder we're about halfway to twelve
hundred dollars at which point i will
shave in the shape of your choice
tomorrow on the break room so we're
gonna have to boost up the super chats
for that but that's okay you know what
i'm planning on going out and joining
hookup culture this weekend oh if my
chest is looking right that's fine if
you don't make me shave something stupid
in it that's all your loss let me buy
you a stock up your daughters yesterday
on this weekend tommy's on the prowl
yesterday i was in the park hooping it
up with the other ballers when a bird of
prey swooped down to my eye level
suddenly a nearby toddler sounded mommy
that bird is staring down a sasquatch
the moral of the story is if i had just
manscaped we would have avoided this
whole conflict and that's why we want to
thank manscape for sponsoring the break
room this week the grooming package that
i highly recommend is the performance
package
4.0 inside the package is the lawn mower
this electric trimmer is your hole
hedges shrubs bushes worst nightmare
there it is mowing your lawn like a
landscaper putin in work the trimmer is
designed to reduce grooming accidents
which are let me tell you no picnic
especially on the weekend shave hair on
loose skin thanks to a ceramic blade and
their advanced skin safe technology no
need for night vision goggles because
this bad boy has an led light on it
although i always say
if you're feeling lonely if you're
feeling like brave if you're feeling
like you want to take a risk in your
life turn the lights off and go to town
on your package you know what that's
that's what the lawnmower can do for you
with the performance package purchase
you get two free gifts two not one but
two the shed travel bag which is
actually very useful in the patented
high performance reduced chafing
manscape boxes i'm talking free
underwear so after you get those gems
all polished you put them in a nice sack
a nice bag a nice carrying case a bunch
of other products to help you
on their website to maximize your
confidence and your grooming gaming you
get 20 off plus free shipping when you
use our code break room at manscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com but you have to use our
code break room otherwise i'm gonna find
out so keep your lawn clean and pristine
with the ultimate bush whacking tool
from manscaped oh that's lovely uh and
big shout out to td jones who helped
push us over the super
a frequent hero in the super chat he
said bring on the clown bring him uh
he's not the only one though we also
want to thank reid coles
i think for joker 2 it'll be like the
wizard of oz a bit where they go back
deep in his past they go into therapy
sessions and when there's people in the
past it could be people from the place
all right
all the people in arkham asylum
she's playing harley right they say
harley quinn they're not saying harleen
quinzel right but i think if they say
harley harleen quinzel oh my dad's
calling me he's like what the hell is
this
i want to see it but i don't understand
these characters
i just wish that they all only boys
kissed girl yes
uh anyway
ah sorry
we're running up somewhere else
to see who who who will be the biggest
clown
saying disney marvel took hawkeye out of
the limited series category and put it
in the best series category for that
that means thank you that's exactly what
it was that's right yeah yeah they did
it for hot guys so they took it out of
the limited series
j master also a hero of the super chats
we see you jay tommy all right i'm
getting my face painted but while i'm
getting my face painted i have to do
mandatory fun too so can we do you want
to do that first yeah yeah start
mandatory fun all right i'm gonna
introduce mantory fun listen we are
singing
songs today lady gaga joined the cast of
joker 2. we had no choice but to jokerfy
some lady gaga songs now jessica is a
little under the weather she's got a
scratchy throat we covet tested her
and she's negative
so she's just going to judge but the
other that the other three of us are
gonna have to sing a lady gaga song
joker five who wants to go first well
i'm getting i think i need to know why
you're getting joker and man just
catching uh a sight of jessica in the
background with the the clown makeup a
little bit
[Applause]
uh it reminds me of when i go to the
bathroom every night uh before bed and i
look in the mirror and for a second i
see a figure behind me oh god when i
turn
oh it's just that's just me
okay white timer gets jokered up uh i'm
gonna do my song this is this song is
called birth of harley which is to the
tune of edge of glory if you're familiar
with lady gaga's catalogue
um
okay they put you in the asylum all
alone or come yeah baby come on yeah
baby but i got a reason that we should
break you out tonight
i need a pudding that makes me laugh
when it's so wrong or come yeah baby
i'll come yeah baby
breaking into bank spaces where we both
belong tonight
it's time to paint our face and blow up
this place i'm gonna joke with you do
some crime with you and then call you mr
jay
i'll turn it again
to harley
and i'm putting on a harlequin suit
i'm turning in
to harley
and i'm putting on that harlequin suit i
am the queen the queen the queen the
queen the queen the queen the queen
i'm turning in
to holly
and i'm putting on a hurricane suit yeah
turn it into holly with you
yeah there you go no idea how hard it
was to not laugh during that
my daughter i think i was pretty easy to
not laugh
i think it was wonderful
is it ready is it ready
yes
do you have anything to say before you
want to turn around all i have to say is
my mama told me when i was young your
job is to make the whole world laugh
i paint my face and put my lipstick on
stuff for breath out with my grass
i'll be moving my way cause i'm really
quickly i'm the joker baby i was born
this way i killed a late night host and
that isn't a boast i'm telling jokes now
baby i was born this way
don't be a drag just be a clown don't be
a drag just be a clown don't be a drag
just be a clown i'm evil in my own way
cause i'm really quick
i'm the joker baby i was born this way
beautiful beautiful boy beautiful also
alex see i saw you in the chat during me
key of ouch i will find
i will find you alex
when you're in zach's seat you just
inherently become a scratchy i feel like
his spirit you dance like this yeah
there's dna's in that [ __ ] pick up his
dna's on the chair
oh my gosh what happened isn't this nice
it's my little crying baby oh i like the
little accent of white it really makes
us shine the tears indicative oh you
didn't say your joke yeah oh my joke
yeah don't watch your hat i don't want
you to get it oh red on it yeah if i get
any hat on my mammoth head wear hat
mammoth headwear for men with big heads
uh my joke is uh
how much does a chimney cost
how much how much nothing
it's on the house
someone shoot me in the face you're goon
number one i'm good no he's good number
one
he's a good gun
that joke kills
yeah
oh yeah baby all right come on someone
else get their face freaking painted
here
did we play the graphic
oh yeah sorry it's mandatory fun
hey there it is sorry you know i got a
little loosey-goosey so excited to get
clown i knew i was getting my face
painted so i said uh don't play the
graphic
to later hit it again
oh that's right this is mandatory fun
every day every dang day i get my three
best friends in the whole world together
to have a little non-optional joy with
me
as we said we are doing lady gaga songs
only one man has not sung yet eric hey
are you ready
we'll find out let's just go
all right
so
i'm doing poker face what it's called
it's actually now joker
beautiful clowns love puns yes
i wanna joke them like they do and stand
up please set it up tell the punchline
yeah tag it you're thinking the wrong
song
i'll take it with you do it
and if the joke's not working i just rip
[Applause]
came out of retirement to help me sing
the right
wonderful
now
jessica yes as always we have to take
mandatory fun very seriously very
seriously we need to know who's moving
on to hollywood who's moving on to the
next phase i'll get the golden buzzer
lady gaga joker idol
i loved the enthusiasm
from tommy
i love the jokes that came from you guys
for brandon
i love the duet that came from erica
oh my god whatever happens you guys i
love both of you whatever happens i'm
just so you're brothers
one wins today
and it's tommy back
in my own way because i'm really quickly
i'm the joker baby i was born this way
oh no you're only saying that because
you dressed him up as a car yes he's my
goon number one my good boy
he's my good time boy my sweet cheese my
rotten soldier
oh my god he's my pal he's my humble
this is the best part you guys we just
need a little bit more so i can get
brandon or eric's face but we have
enough time
to do something that was like i've never
been here this is a big day folks wow
it's been a long week
a lot has happened this week but this is
a bit that we rode on monday and it's
finally time we got some big updates
today this would have been monday
regarding the new star wars series
coming to andor coming to disney plus
called andorra hey yes guys we're gonna
talk about and wait wait we have
breaking news
they released a new trailer on monday
along with some new information around
the release date which has been pushed
back to september 21st so they're gonna
drop three episodes on the premiere date
september 21st uh with this season and
or is gonna have 12 episodes total which
is kind of big for like a a series this
will be the longest that's
12 episodes 12 episodes is a lot it's a
nice little song are they our do you
think they're hour-long episodes i heard
they're each three and a half hours
[ __ ] you better be joking
i'm sure they're under an hour i'm sure
they clock in around like 44 or 38 12
episodes 12 episodes yeah
i wouldn't say it's bad it's just
yeah no i do want to say sorry uh
although i was the winner as judged by
jessica the only judge in the
competition we did still pull our idiot
viewers who are as we all know garbage
and they're not trustworthy and they
somehow for some reason thought that
eric
uh was the best one by two percentage
points
our uneducated borderline inbred
viewership has once again failed to
deliver that baby positive change take
yourselves outside get up on your roofs
and dive into your garbage can oh my god
i hope they're empty oh my gosh i'm
going to north korea
uh yeah andorra is coming we're excited
all right all right that's okay uh i
mean they announced that daredevil is
going to have 18 episodes which is
another big in history yeah this is
brilliant
daredevil born again but andorra is
coming soon we're going to get three
episodes
three episodes that first night which
will be like heavy that's a lot so then
it feels like actual eight yeah so it'll
feel like less over time i'm sure uh but
that'll be like a big night i think the
biggest news for me out of this trailer
which this was i think a really good
trailer really set the tone for this
show it looks great it looks like they
actually filmed a lot on real places and
not as much of the volume which we all
enjoy but i think we're starting our
eyes have caught up to the volume and
now we're starting to see that you can
feel what it's like a close set yeah uh
but a lot of great shots in it finally a
lot of andor himself
not in a lot of the earlier trailers
guard but most importantly
guys my boy saw herrera is back
if you're a fan of the clone wars
animated stuff if you're a fan of rogue
one and you saw the end
of saw guerrero gonna get the boot
guillot
i'm so excited to see saw guerrero back
in this man forest whitaker goes crazy
as this yeah
i am hyped up i hope he's i don't know
what condition he's in at this point
this is a few years before rogue one
like two or three forest himself looks
very
like a little more slender morris looks
i don't know if he'll be doing the
breathing thing because that was my
favorite part
oh right because he has the whole like
he has all the tubing yeah yeah he's
taking a lot of damage if you've watched
the clone wars
kind of like batman the animated series
mr freeze tubing like remember the mr
freeze in that one yeah
that went in yes i like it graveyards
are getting chucked in the trash thank
you for the super chat
we will throw you in the trash uh i'm
also we're also hyped about this
uh it looks like someone else who's the
same species as maz kanata from the
the the trilogy
uh the yeah
the three sequels yeah
there's another one we don't know what
maz kanata is but we know maz kanata f's
confirmed yeah we know mascara gets gets
gets busy beats cheeks yes right she
beats cheeks
actually make that thumbnail
well this is what blows my mind about
like star wars like it's fine
you're bleeding
star wars that like they don't know what
yoda is right there's yoda there's yeah
now there's grogu we don't know where
they are we don't know what planet they
come from that's fine you can have one
yeah you cannot have two yeah okay and
the entire star wars universe they don't
know what maz kanata is just follow her
home i don't know like
what what what are you where are you
listen i've done that at the airport a
few times with very bad results
this is the thing kanata beats cheeks
yoda slams hams either way you gotta let
them do their thing yoda's loving it
uh but i am excited to learn maybe more
about this character maybe get a name
for its species the wikipedia is just
waiting it's just dying to fill up that
entry oh yeah let's call them canadians
can audiences like canadians oh i like
that
that's a good pronunciation oh so good
to see you
yeah overall i think this is just like a
really kind of fresh look no tattooing
as far as we can tell yeah
someone in the chat i think it was
yesterday was like i want more tattoos
they're trolling they're trolls because
they're garbage they live under bridges
genuinely do want more tattoos anyone in
this chat who wants what else is going
to learn
you can catch my after show where we'll
talk about that called catch these hands
where i take people who want more
tattooing and i take them outside and i
rough them up and then i kiss them but
this
all right i want more tattooing yeah
where are you this show is also going to
give us more of what i wanted from like
tala in ob1 where it was like oh this is
a person who works for the empire but
it's kind of like a rebel at heart
sneaking around using that like i wanted
more of that story and that's what we're
going to get here like these kind of
andors like infiltrated the empire uh
skarsgard who knows what he's up to
fiona shaw's character is ripping stuff
up from the inside i love this i want to
see more of the senate i want more
bureaucracy i want more sitting around
and talking that's what i wanted my star
wars
i want the the the machinations
episode 2 council meetings yes i don't
need to see a whole lightsaber in this
entire show i don't want to see a single
light why are you don't need to see the
land i don't want to see a jedi i want
to see i want to see bureaucracy
long flowing ropes speeches in front of
the south
in the chat give me tauntauns give me
heart yeah the time times get a
representative in the senate
they've got to have a translator or two
they do provide lodging
for some galactic senators
and not others
travel accommodations provided by tomtom
[Music]
[Applause]
someone's getting painted someone's
getting painted someone's
miguel's a king for sending in a very
gracious super chat with respect singing
without zach white dancing is matt you
know we did our best we take your
respect we take your fifty dollars and
we take you out to the trash where you
belong technically white dancing is what
both of these two games yeah yeah what
are you talking about where that is my
dancing transcends race
that's what i think it's so
offensive it offends everyone even white
people don't want to associate with it
they're like that's not ours either
we want to thank skippy cox for sending
in super chat keep painting faces love
listening to you guys
give us your best
i think they're asking for your best
laugh
yeah give her your best joker laugh okay
okay i'll go okay
that's a good one
i got a good one
bucky barnes atl says nfl starts tonight
bill's mafia and don pounds baby
mafia
why'd you make that noise for a bit
aren't you guys yeah what's that i can't
give him a dog that's
cleveland okay okay
long-suffering city of cleveland come on
it's joe we gotta be nice to get that
graveyard 3503. it wants to be thrown in
the trash with him in the trash uh
matthew nanya then your business
what movie do y'all want to see set
during the snap
during this probably shawshank
redemption
take a regular movement instead of
turning yeah yeah yeah just be like that
guy does it in real life yeah yeah just
be really annoying movie watcher i heard
that girl dusted
he's alive he survived i once saw an
avenger 50 years ago now they're
everywhere
the whole dang what
movement i'll do brandon first and then
thank you
yes thank you
oh tanisha massey's sending in a super
chat to face paid for everyone for
everyone
come here brandon oh joe wants to be
treated like trash to the trash johnny
taking over while i get my face to the
disposal
everybody's
listen
i'm gonna get i'm taking control of the
show
uh detroit tigers baseball's in shambles
let's be honest ever since casey mize
got tommy john tariq skubal's out with
an injury we can't do anything so all i
got left is these buffalo bills and they
got heart baby they got heart they got
talent they got players that don't
really want to be here anti-facts
quarterback they're a quarterback he's
not anti-max your quarterback simply
says do your own research which by the
way
is not a good point you should not
listen to him you should not you should
follow blindly into everything as john
says can you make the baseball talk
about andor somehow yes okay so andorra
i think could you imagine the baseball
team in star wars yes let's cast our
dream star wars baseball team okay
batboy little luke skywalker
you're starting with bad boy for
yourself
oh yeah there's the little kid with the
broom at the end of the last jedi uh
okay
uh equipment manager maz
uh always there with the gadgets
okay uh at catcher
job of the hut why he's as big as the
backstop big hands okay right a pitcher
i'm gonna say jar jar binks because
listen to me listen to me we all make
fun of jar jar binks but he could fling
things
really fast oh yeah really fast so if
jar jar binks is pitching at shortstop
hope one can never be hello there you
know you need someone agile so i'm going
to stop the balls
at first base my boy darth vader why
because you got to be a vacuum cleaner
at first base you got to be a vacuum
cleaner a ball's in the dirt
stop it with a force
there it is okay second base
traditionally you know not your best arm
but slick with a glove so someone who's
not very strong but someone who's very
slick i'm talking about dryden voss paul
bettany from solo a star wars sword with
the sticky fingers gripping the ball
underhanded vader turning facing okay
this is the best ramping i can do
third base you got to have a strong arm
third base i'm saying chewbacca
chewbacca and third base
that's him throwing you off let's get to
the outfield in right field charisma
strong hitting strong tenacity willing
to be a bit of a bastard lando
calrissian
okay
center field is where you get the speed
that is aged luke skywalker that is luke
skywalker had a at an appropriate
age and a report
what's that last channel
too
no i'm talking uh return to the jedi
luke skywalker and finally in left field
rounding out the whole team it's old
faithful qui-gon jinn where have you
been i've been waiting for you
why because left fielders are annoying
okay they're the leaders of the outfield
i play left field i'm better than the
right fielder statistically most balls
get hit to me yeah
qui-gon
stay dead homie can we get out of this
close-up yeah
uh hey chrissy asked if moon knight 2
does release the other gods trapped in
the u-shaped i want best to be played by
danny devito
look up what
chrissy we can't look things up we're
live look up what the description of
best look like and you'll know why it's
perfect for the people at home their
computers go look it up
turn
[Music]
we're big fans of john wayne on the
break room john wayne or john wayne
gates oh anyone that starts with john
wayne john wayne bobbitt john wayne
gates the big three the tribunal thank
you
tyler we were talking before okay the
mics are going crazy
before can you turn it
off yes but let me say this one thing
ethan hawke said uh he was like is is
yeah he was very much like his hero dead
do we know the writer jake sullivan
right uh uh no jeremy jeremy i don't
know jake sullivan jeremy slater said uh
the writer for the show said he always
imagined when he wrote like the finale
that like harold was dead and that was
like the end of the story but again
that's not up to a writer always and
they kind of left it open and harrow's
got a gun inside of him yeah trapped
inside of him so who knows what that
means when you shoot arrow i'll say this
too right like off-screen
off-screen
off-screen death also we know kingpin
just got shot in the face in hawkeye and
he's coming back in
daredevil yeah
stop moving honey are you making me come
back yeah yeah i like the idea of harold
being back am i kind of coming back
ethan hawk was great and he brought a
lot of fun to that show
i wouldn't mind if he came back i i
think he could just expand about what he
is a little bit more i need to know why
he had glass in his shoes and i need to
see more glass shoes and what was he
drinking at the beginning what was in
the drink what's in the drink can you
take any luxuriously with our faces
i think it was just water you don't
think it was vodka or everclear
probably ever clear to deal with the
glassy feet
graveyard that's high praise you're
still trash
the glass in the shoe and this is
something that like ethan hawkins said
when he was asked about the character
was that like this character doesn't
think he's doing anything wrong he
thinks he's doing the right thing and i
want more history about him conscious
what what i thought he was lying about
that yeah yeah yeah but it seemed to be
true yeah he was basically the only one
in that history what did he do and
marvel you got the d aging tech yeah
throw ethan hawk on there show us what
happened 20 years ago yeah
doesn't he have a son i know
[Applause]
yeah um yeah but i i i am excited for
like a moon night too yes and bring back
ethan hogg i'm excited for andor can't
wait for that because rogue one was so
great i want to see more espionage i
want to see the rebels get dirty get
play play yeah give me more more like
rotten soldiers in in the uh in the
rebellion you know what i'm saying like
let's find out who the scumbags in the
rebellion were they were willing to do
some bad you know do some bad to get
some good good doing what is this vanity
project
oh this is crazy this is probably the
worst part of this is we're now
dangerously close to me getting my chest
shaved and i'm not happy about it you
all raised too much money uh yes thank
you i was away for a minute thank you
hey john come to the white i didn't see
i didn't get to see it you were zoomed
in on the darkness thank you to all of
you oh my god you're gorgeous you're
beautiful
you're
beautiful thank you to all our super
chatters today
uh graveyard 3503 sending a super chat
saying tom you gave patton a run for the
money with your star wars rant if you
like that clip it out submit it on our
discord for the clip of the week we've
been getting a lot of submissions this
week we're so excited we're doing our
clip of the week uh uh you submit them
on our discord and we'll pick out our
favorite one and show it at the end of
the week and give you all the credit for
it oh god
our awesomeness i'm just as confused as
you are i was doing the makeup came back
if you're just tuning in they decided to
fill the time and i just did the only
thing i knew
we got a real goon squad here you guys
want to hear some more joker jokes yeah
why did the werewolf leave summer camp
early why because he missed his mummy ah
i don't like that okay i got another one
okay
what
john i'm just laughing thank you
okay john uh why why does santa always
cough before he goes in the chimney why
because it's coming down to something
oh my gosh
huh
jimmy joe two chimney chimney joe yeah
oh i i didn't introduce myself i'm don
chimney my dad
nice to meet you nice to meet you i'm
the chimney clan yeah yeah we don't like
to refer to ourselves as a clan anymore
ever since we uh we left virginia but uh
no shout out to all our virginia viewers
your trash bags
uh corey candrill said they had a super
chat what if wong is just our sherpa
through the mystical slash paranormal
and he's the one who creates and brings
together the midnight suns
midnight suns
i mean he's seen some dark stuff that's
right he doesn't faze him no he's just
like just another giant one-eyed
tentacle monster
magic people are just like these things
they're like yeah people die people live
people explode people vaporize it's all
just part of magic honey yeah well it's
pretty like jaded so if he were to bring
together the midnight signs you'd know
someone had to have forced his
way to their hand he's like i need a
dark team to kill him
your face is traumatizing what it is
because you are so handsome and then i
looked over at you and you have this
just devastating face pain
like modern art i like it yeah thank you
very much we get all the boomerangs all
of them all the boomerangs also
christie's sending out super chat
there's an alternate ending in the iniad
chamber in the final episode that may
stunt double did a wire pull for and
shared on her insta it's a scene where
harrah woke up and attacked them
so yeah i think you know i think we're
all right a little off-screen death
means you're not really yeah you're not
really dead
you're not really it's not over until no
one ever really uh
and yeah you know what the show never
really dies it keeps going on and on
because we're here live every day that's
right from our very own break room here
at new rockstars headquarters and we
want to thank you for joining us the
whole goon squad today
i'll never be able to sleep this evening
thank you to all of our super chatters
today thank you for sticking around
throw a like on that video if you
haven't already be sure to hop on our
discord where you can clip out your
favorite clip from the show and submit
it as the clip of the week uh or you can
also leave us a voicemail send in a
voicemail we might answer it on the show
we've been collecting them making us a
fine little catalog and we're going to
rip those out before you know it uh but
thanks for joining us and as always
stay good
stay gucci the mood thank you
come back tomorrow for the big friday
show we thank you all for joining us and
we hope you we hope you have a great
rest of your thursday we love you later
gators bye breakers bye roomies